nos dicen que en burritos la huerta
preparan un aderezo mezclando dos
cucharadas de miel con media cucharada
de mostaza en salsas y tacos preparan un
aderezo mezclando cuatro cucharadas de
miel con una cucharada de mostaza cuál
de los aderezos tiene un sabor de
mostaza más intenso pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo muy bien pensemos
en la proporción de miel y mostaza en
cada uno de los restaurantes primero
vamos a pensar en lo que pasa en
burritos la huerta para abreviar vamos a
decir bh burritos la huerta ellos usan
dos cucharadas de miel por cada media
cucharada de mostaza entonces la
proporción de miel y mostaza en términos
de cucharadas es de dos cucharadas de
miel por cada media cucharada de mostaza
esta es la proporción de miel a mostaza
déjenme escribirlo esto es miel y esto
de acá es mostaza
ahora vamos a ver salsas y tacos le voy
a llamar ese te salsas y tacos hace un
aderezo mezclando 4 cucharadas de miel
con una cucharada de mostaza la
proporción de miel y mostaza es de 4
cucharadas a una una vez más esto es
miel y esto es mostaza
ahora podemos hacer que éstas sean
proporciones equivalentes o podemos
compararlas de alguna manera bueno vamos
a ver aquí tenemos media cucharada de
mostaza y aquí tenemos una cucharada de
mostaza que pasa si multiplicamos las
cucharadas de miel y mostaza por dos eso
seguiría siendo una proporción
equivalente porque estamos multiplicando
por la misma cifra de modo que si
multiplicamos por dos en los dos casos
tenemos cuatro cucharadas de miel por
cada cucharada de mostaza bueno es
exactamente la misma proporción que
tenemos en salsas y tacos así que en
realidad resulta que tiene la misma
concentración de mostaza tienen la misma
proporción de miel y mostaza 4 a 14
cucharadas de miel por cada cucharada de
mostaza en cada uno de los casos hagamos
otro ejemplo
aquí nos dicen que el tono favorito de
pintura morada de patricio se logra con
4 litros de pintura azul y voy a
subrayar esto en azul 4 litros de
pintura azul por cada 3 litros de
pintura roja por cada 3 litros de
pintura roja de modo que la proporción
de pintura azul y pintura roja es de 4
litros de pintura azul por cada 3 litros
de pintura roja la proporción es 4 a 3
con cuál de las siguientes mezclas de
pintura se logra el mismo tono de morado
muy bien pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo aquí tenemos 3 litros de
pintura azul mezclada con 4 litros de
pintura roja bueno aquí tenemos una
proporción de 3 a 4 y aunque estamos
manejando las mismas cantidades la
proporción es diferente el orden es
importante aquí dice 4 litros de azul
por cada 3 litros de rojo y acá dice 3
litros de azul por cada 4 litros de rojo
así que podemos descartar ésta
8 litros de pintura azul mezclada con 6
litros de pintura roja aquí la
proporción es de 8 litros de azul por
cada 6 litros de rojo bueno estas son
proporciones equivalentes si
multiplicamos por 2 en ambos casos vamos
a obtener una proporción de 8 a 64 por 2
es igual a 8 3 por 2 es igual a 6 de
modo que esto sin duda es una proporción
equivalente así que vamos a seleccionar
esta opción
muy bien aquí dice 6 litros de pintura
azul mezclada con 8 litros de pintura
roja aquí han cambiado el azul por el
rojo en relación con esta de modo que
tenemos una proporción de 6 a 8 voy a
escribirlo aquí esta proporción es de 6
litros de pintura azul por cada 8 litros
de pintura roja así como la primera en
esta opción tenemos los mismos números
pero en diferente orden y el orden
importa de modo que la descartamos 20
litros de pintura azul 20 litros de
pintura azul por cada 15 litros de
pintura roja
estas son equivalentes pensemos un poco
en esto para pasar de 4 a 20 podemos
multiplicar por 5 y para pasar de 3 a 15
podemos multiplicar por 5 podemos
multiplicar por el mismo factor para
pasar de la proporción de 4 a 3 a la
proporción de 20 a 15 esta es sin duda
una proporción equivalente
12 litros de pintura azul mezclada con
16 litros de pintura roja muy bien aquí
tenemos una proporción de 12 litros de
pintura azul por cada 16 de pintura roja
pensemos en esto para pasar de 4 a 12
deberíamos multiplicar por 3 ahora si
multiplicamos 3 por tres tendremos un 9
aquí no un 16 definitivamente esta no es
una proporción equivalente otra forma de
pensar en esto es que en términos de
litros tenemos más litros de azul que de
rojo en cada una de las proporciones
equivalentes pero aquí tenemos más
litros de rojo que de azul esta es otra
manera de reconocer que no son
equivalentes solo weide son mezclas
equivalentes que lograrán el mismo tono
de morado para lograr el mismo tono
necesitamos la misma proporción de azul
y rojo terminamos